hey everyone welcome back to the game
sports stage here at e3 2017 joining
myself antomattei is michael de plata
from monolith very excited with what
you're bringing with you we're going to
watch well there's going to be a live
gameplay demo of middle-earth shadow of
war should we dive straight in yeah
let's let's go so here we are we've got
Evan over here playing and the fun thing
with all of these demos is we really
don't know what's going to happen
anytime you do it so we don't know who
the enemies are going to be our
followers are going to be and what's
going to happen but we're actually kind
of deep behind enemy lines here and
we're in the south of Mordor kind of a
lush breadbasket of Mordor and our goal
is going to be to conquer this fortress
that we can tell look at that that's way
better than anything that we can see
ahead of us and one of the things just
to notice depending on which orc tribe
is controlling this area it's going to
actually change not just the fortress
but also the life kind of throughout the
open-world in this region and we're
facing a machine fortress here so these
guys are heavily into kind of
destruction of nature and
industrializing mortal and that's set by
the Overlord that we can see so this is
scag the anvil machine tank so he's in
charge of the region and he's who Evans
going to need to defeat if we want to
conquer this region and take it over but
in order to get to him we're going to
have to fight our way through these
various Warchief so here we got our
ghoul the ogre it's fun because it just
every single time we're just seeing any
name we've never met before
see the problem with that is there's a
very low chance of Bruce showing up now
we were absolutes which are ever the
Xbox absolutely the thing oh thank you
here to come like I don't care about
tallying anymore I'm just get rid of
that guy makes change the protagonist
yeah yeah oh yeah be happy with that
Bruce would be totally down with that
but I mean all these guys have got a ton
of personality The Alchemist so I'm
going to guess he's actually responsible
for kind of brewing the grog that keeps
the orc war machine going and keeps the
crazy and motivated as they are and so
all of these guys the blue these are all
our followers commander so taro tribe
these guys are really good in large
battles because they're going to inspire
the other troops that are around them
but I guess does I work in the opposite
way like if he gets defeated we'll some
of our followers sort of maybe lose
courage in battle demoralize yeah yes so
the death in battle of the different
captains that can spread a morale effect
and then not only that but how they die
so we have a whole new layer to the
combat now like brutal executions and
attacks so you can build up we'll see
when we get in there the mic bar and
actually when you know limbs start
flying and people start getting
eviscerated that can actually spread
terror and make guys start fleeing as
well
all right time to take the fortress
Akbar it's a immediately noticing like
this is way more colorful than anything
I've seen this is a new area I've not
seen this area before even though I have
played the game and it looks way more
vibrant than any of the previous areas
that I've seen so it's good to see that
you guys have kind of like as well as
increasing the scale of the game you've
introduced a lot more like visual
variety and identities the areas
yeah and that's everything from the sort
of geology of the area to the vegetation
systems completely revamped and then
even all of those things then interact
with the gameplay because more
vegetation means more stealth it means
more opportunities for fire that's red
so we're really trying to bring the
whole whole sandbox to life actually one
other thing I just wanted to point out
that we can do here as well as we can as
you're working preparing to go and
charge into combat you can select your
team and basically match them up against
the enemies but then for every single
one of your followers that you're
bringing in in your army you can also
equip different upgrades to the actual
attacking force so will you always be
able to see like what the stronghold has
and so you can counter it or will some
of it be chemistry that you have to it's
a function of getting Intel so you have
different ways of getting Intel you can
find Intel in enemy camps or on war
tables or by interrogating certain
enemies and if you have that Intel then
that'll enable you to obviously prepare
more and then the other thing you can do
is you can actually
infiltrate spies into the enemy camp so
we have them the mechanism of making
spires last time but now we can kind of
really pay that off by actually getting
guys behind enemy lines during the
assault can't a lien go in behind enemy
lines and sort of like I remember in
barb actually playing a shadow model
right now and I could go in and like
poison Grogg yep
can can I do that before I do the forts
on the way to prepare the fortress
before the assault is to even how to
assassinate the enemy WarChiefs
and then so not only are you going to
kill that war chief you're also going to
disable whatever upgrade or defense he
was responsible for so it's about
manipulating the enemies kind of like
ranks to kind of strike when you do
instead of going in there doing
something on his waiting yes yeah
exactly
and then yeah so you prepare for the
battle and then you can launch the fort
assault ok he's giving us some smack
talk here it's a lot of a noise in this
game there's a lot more like volkl
delivery of smack talk van of yesterday
during the press conference there was
that guy who was the kind of hunting him
for a wall and he sounded like he
delivered a life story that was
interesting so that was the machine so
yes like so there's a couple of things
that we actually have that a new around
that one is last time we had scars but
this time we've kind of taken that to a
whole new level where we really get
these super villains with him we'd
actually you know 70s arm off crushed
his head once before and then he'd
essentially been completely rebuilt as
this new character and then they can
actually earn different titles so he'd
actually sort of turned him into this
full-scale super villain and it's just a
way we just want to continue and build
these stories that you have with the the
orcs alright what hang on okay sorry so
kind of Legolas esque way to mount here
yes and so this is actually Evans for
his own war machines in he's also bought
that Drake in again over to the the
right the Drake's are generally wild so
they're just gonna spread havoc and fire
everywhere but they they fired like
indiscriminately right cuz I when we
played was it this mission or very
similar a similar one not
on and I brought a Drake in and he was
raining fire down on my I did that same
thing it's not easy to tame a Drake and
also so you can see the blue icons
represent our followers the letters are
the victory points we're trying to take
control of those two decreasing red
circles on the left at some of Evans
followers who are now bleeding out in
combat as well
other drunk I love this epic is epic
epic epic Lee drunk let me just talk
about failing upwards Wow you've got
quite a few metal beard that's a great
name that's my favorite thing about
these games yeah then have you got like
a generator here how are you coming up
with these names it's really interesting
like the amount of work that went into
this game versus shadow of Mordor in the
sense like we weren't so much a shadow
model we had the Nemesis system and we
have these great auks and we love them
but just because we were able to sorry
it reached by a blemish but acrobatic
Pat call is it is I follow I am so upset
yeah so you'll find a lot of work into
these quirky names but now well now sort
of the name so often if you get the the
name and the personality and the class
and the armor and the flare and the
traits because we just have so much more
content wow that's just me is it oh I'll
be sent home in a box
yeah someone's gonna see that happen to
Bruce one day yeah that's when you reset
yeah and oh okay
so the commander that we had see that
banner is actually being planted in the
victory point and once they planted
those banners that's actually going to
inflame the other orc so it's gonna send
all the grunts into a frenzy so one of
the new kind of combat systems that you
added was like the new weapon so to
control crowds that I found really
useful oh yeah and I was playing it yeah
yeah talk a little bit about decision to
introduce that and obviously it makes
sense why you would do that but it also
speaks to kind of the scale of the
battles now right yeah and the that
crowd control element and
you think so the glaive a little yeah
there we go
but yeah it's partly because just the
scale of the battles has increased so
much so now you've got you know hundreds
of enemies and allies floating around
and also just being able to sort of mix
it up between sort of building your hit
counter and building up the might and
they're mixing it up with these heavier
attacks and then it also lets us extend
that through the skill tree as well so
now there's different ways you can
upgrade or augment all those weapons
including the glaive I think one of my
favorite skills in the game is actually
you can double charge the glaive the
spear and then unleash that in sort of
combos and your way around the battle as
well so we've really tried to make the
combat a lot deeper yeah more
challenging and give a lot more traits
to the enemies but then also let players
customize the skill tree too you know
how they want to play as well is they're
going to be like so in shadow model when
you defeated a captain you would get
like a specific room that would sort of
remind you of the battle and who you
defeated is it going to be the same work
in the same way with the new loot drops
we've actually doubled down on that in a
couple of ways because caliber in boar
as this sort of mighty Smith is you know
we want this idea that he's actually
crafting this loot yeah as a way of
immortalizing or commemorating these
different enemies he's defeated he's the
yeah so they're not actually carrying
around rings of power or anything like
that he's crafting them in response to
these victories yeah and so we want the
loot to immortalize these enemies and
these stories you built up so if you
have like you can see there's the golden
one over there that Oh humiliation on
him it was going so well
it was an amazing backdrop waiting god
it was an incredible backflip into a
slow-motion arrow and then a teleport
and I was like well this is going real
well and that was going on in there's
always a drink yeah oh wow and I was
saying with the volute so if we grab one
of these epic pieces in a second no no
poor girl irrational response yeah
but not only does the loot actually
record the name of the orc who dropped
it
but it actually creates a challenge in
the game that you can play that will
relate to whatever his story was if he
had flame weapons for example maybe
you've got to burn a number of guys and
then when you complete that challenge
that'll actually unlock additional
traits that will be related what he was
like so maybe it's setting guys on fire
and a little quote to like him as well
so you're luke is always almost like a
little series of gravestones or the
history of all of these orcs you've
defeated so we see here we've taken the
Drake into battle and we sort of he's
been worn down yup now we can dominate
him and take him yes exactly like though
yeah yeah yeah so this I think the thing
that is really key for people to like
pick up on is it's such a multi tiered
but every one of these like the first
time I played it I will happily admit
that I got destroyed repeatedly because
you have to think about so much at one
moment there's a lot of systems overlaid
on top of each other so if you're kind
of a gamer who really likes to get
involved in these various systems and
how they all link into each other this
game feels like it's going to deliver a
lot of that oh yeah it is like the chaos
of battle it really kind of brings that
out I felt when I played it I guess that
rule yeah there we go running up I mean
and because the thing is so here at e3
for example because we have limited time
or when you guys are playing the game
we're just kind of throwing you into
these four assaults but the experience
of when you play the whole game is
you've got the whole open-world and
you've got all of these different ways
you can prepare for that either of
building up your own army or of wearing
down and weakening the enemy or of
studying their Intel so you can we
always want players to have just so much
choice about how they build their own
stories when charging straight into
combat this guy's actually laundry yep
nice burst there's two confused how far
into the game is this fortress assault
this would probably be sort of a third
of the way into the into the game so
we've gotten past kind of the opening
story and the opening act we've
introduced all the different skills and
abilities and then we've opened up more
door so now you can choose
or do you want to conquer it in as well
because I mean I replay in the first
game of the moment I being able to
dominate or cayenne dogs doesn't come
until like quite late into the game but
when it does it's like a massive game
changer are you kind of going to start
off the game being able to do that or is
Akande quite a gradual process to get
into it we should have thought about
that through the lens of the story and
also teaching the game so we do actually
have it like when you begin or early in
the game yeah we're focusing on teaching
the action and the systems and the
Nemesis system and then we build towards
the Ring of Power increasing of its
power and then reintroducing the
domination and so on but we went back
and forward a lot on that in terms of
what's the optimal amount of time and
kind of teaching and producing those
things but then once you do I think the
big difference from shadow of Mordor is
that once you do get that ring of power
and once you can dominate your enemies
it changes the game in so much more of a
meaningful way not only because you've
now got a much bigger goal because
you're trying to conquer Mordor and
actually take on sauer on but also even
in the game itself like another area
we've expanded a lot is the infighting
so if you have two orcs that are in
combat with each other depending on
their class and their level and their
hate and their fears so building your
army is just a lot more interesting this
time and there's a lot going on here I'm
trying to follow what's going on and
like every few seconds two or three
other autre they've got a beef
it is a slaughter yeah yeah so if we let
our followers go in here could they take
basically rid this point of all of the
enemies and then you can just sort of
waltz in or do you sort of have to be
there to plant the flag it would it
would depend on how powerful your
followers were how powerful the enemies
were you would if you did sort of stand
back and leave them to it the defenders
are always going to have the advantage
in terms of the upgrades and the
defenses of the fortress itself and it
is really fun if you invest all the time
you could have a situation where all of
these war chiefs are actually already
spawned right and you just walk up to
the gates and the whole thing just you
know kind of collapse knock on the door
and knock on the door you know there's
something something really satisfying
about that as well in terms of the
our of it I'd love to see like a
saltybet version of this where you can
just like set up your units and just let
the AIS and bet on which how you think
it's going to come out have that twitch
would love that
get that on Twitch you're smiling for
some reason word and that was
interesting that's a very interesting
idea um what I thought was cool that is
that you can sort of shun you can no I
don't wait you can shun you can shame
yep
what is that add to the Nemesis system
like so there's it's it's two things one
there's a level of psychological warfare
to these guys so if you're trying to
sort of break them down if they don't
want to join your army or even just
avenge them sell your self on them if
deaths too good for them or you want to
keep that story going and and then so
the other thing is it does actually
create new story possibilities and new
ways for their personalities to evolve
as well so if they're going to get
iron-willed and kind of defy your
ability to dominate them or if they can
just even become completely deranged
maniacs kind of jason voorhees style as
well so you're really kind of messing
with they're messing with their minds so
it looks like we've reached the kind of
climax of this assault yeah what's going
on here so when we get to enter the
assault depending on the tribe and also
the Overlord that can determine the
traps and the troops and basically what
you're going to be facing in the final
arena and the boss fights right and of
course depending on if you faced him
before as well so if you did fail in a
Ford assault or doing this he's going to
remember that oh yeah so when I when I
played I saw you it was upsetting I got
done in three times was it yeah and
every time I go back he'd be like oh
it's you again yeah but then at the end
um the guy who I was demoing with said
that I got an ending because I came out
and tallien lifted his head him and
threw it over the side he said he'd
never seen that oh really yeah tell me
once there's a fun thing about playing
this game because we've obviously seen
it a lot yeah but you can still you know
as content going in and as the systems
are coming together we see new things
today actually the blue bar that's built
up around the side there that's the
oven rat which is sometimes really handy
to save up for the final Overlord fight
because if you click both the sticks at
that time that's going to unleash
Calabrian borer and he can basically
clear out all of these grunts and it is
possible for you to bring like health
into this kind of two types of help so
you can bring your bodyguard that you've
assigned and you can summon them and if
you've got the ability to summoning
creatures and beasts you can summon
those in as well yeah and that's really
handy if the overlords particular
weakness if he has it like for example
if he had a fear of fire which helped
him very much in here but and you bring
in a follower who has fire weapons or
the if you brought in a Drake that would
probably be pretty handy I did notice
when we were preparing I guess with the
fortress assault a very familiar name
came up she loves brood and we saw a
briefest glimpse of her in the trailer
can you reveal anything about her house
a very large spot it was it well an
uncle Ian yeah yep there was a living
large
Andy and then look at the little spiders
in Mordor they you know Shelob does have
her brood in Mordor so there are those
two separate facts all right okay but we
won't connect any daughter um but what I
did when I talked to you about was that
end wife yeah
ah because explain you know because I
like as a talking fan it's so exciting
to finally I mean you never find out
what happened to them that's the whole
point so was that an exciting moment for
you guys to be able to actually I mean
don't add a little bit more cuz there's
like a throwaway line where it's like
they vanished in the second age they
just went yes and I mean if you listen
to the way Treebeard drones on I mean
can you blame so again that particular
character so can an we haven't sort of
revealed everything about her story and
who she is and the thing is with in
middle-earth with the mire with you know
many different spirits different ways of
different characters that can take
different forms you know whether it's
beyond transforming into a bear or
whether it's the Balrog so she's
definitely a
very powerful character that's really
important within mortal like I think if
you have any well sorry stepping back
but within middle-earth you have a lot
of these characters that are responsible
for protecting nature or yeah me Tom
bom-bom-bom bar deal or beyond or
Treebeard and all these spirits that are
connected to nature and it was really
what would a character of that type be
like to have to survive and to represent
that idea of nature within Mordor
that's going to be a pretty tough job
yeah because I mean looks of it I mean
mortal as a as a place doesn't look like
an area where nature could thrive yes
it's so industrialized and so much
destruction happens there so this is
just me speculating but the cheese sort
of the route as it were bringing back
life bringing back yeah of holding on
your life in that so she's sort of a you
know an underground like a rebel in a
way of holding out for nature even in
this penalty beam yeah in regular
crevasse and this looks like a really
tight spot and it feels very familiar
I'd lost on my planet I was in a very
similar situation where I was
desperately rolling around the edges of
the so when I realized it I kept um oh
hello
annoyed oh yeah every time I played it I
kept having to jump up like a shadow
strike up to the roof you all the arches
turn them onto my side to try and get
them but then they like a bunch of them
kept coming in yeah see that moved the
the combo and sort attack from Calabria
more um in the first game when you use
that move it has one of the best sound
effects in video gave me new sounds
honestly is one of my favorite sounds
like an engine starting on yep and every
time I heard it it make me so happy so
I'm looking for a real that you ever
made that online in the audio tech oh
yeah I will conduct a separate interview
with just him yeah I will definitely
that cuz that sound is incredible
I know someone who looks just like that
Wow Wow the tanks wanna rustle hey he's
not gonna yeah you have got elven wrath
there there we go
Wow Phoebe is not just one wow I'm
getting actually limited other attacks
--is oh that is right little come to
play yeah not messing around
Wow perfect cinematic ending fire rising
at the exact same look oh yes
also the Kesey's have changed instead of
having to go like get it into the center
no just yes oh oh wow
that's a good way to end that nice
fortress fortress go ahead I was I saw
the stuff at the same time but every
time I was looking down yeah oh yeah
this is what I got
yeah I think it's probably for the
viewers worth going back and re watching
this cuz some really cool stuff happened
which we were distracting it I felt
guilty because I was talking about some
of the blocks as well but you know I
really like this Dawei caliber and what
kind of forces were ya know and then so
can the orcs actually see caliber more
doing this or is it like sort of just
amplifying Italians voice are from here
it's actually interesting so we have
this notion of Italian and then we have
Calabrian boy and then we sort of have
the bright lord who's sort of the the
union of those two characters kind of
the Iron Man to the Tony Stark I guess
of when they come together and we really
see the duality and that's a like in the
story trailer that moment where he's
kind of booming out and challenging
Sauron so we actually really explore all
three of those versions as the character
a lot more at different parts of the
story and also as it evolved and as
Calabrian ball gets a bit more
power-crazed as we go on and there's
definitely more we do a lot more with
the duality and with their different
agendas than we did last time and in the
gameplay because now they can have their
own unique animations and weapons and
attacks and kills but also in the story
so now we've got to choose
so now we're in like a fortress
management fees of it yep and get the
opportunity to choose the Overlord which
won't only affect the fortress itself
but it also creates some different
opportunities out within the open world
as well I like these guys so the mystic
tribes going to give us more accursed
totems and vignettes and and once your
fortress is set up it's like you've got
to come back and protect it every now
and then or you can kind of need to run
maintenance and all your fortresses
weasal um don't want you to run
maintenance but we do want you to need
to upgrade it and offend it and the fact
that Sauron will return and will
counter-attack and you will need to
defend it can we do that from a
different menu or on it in the game or
do we have to sort of pop back every now
and then Oh any - you'll know if the
fortress is under assault because
there'll be a CEO icon on it okay
so you got some time well then so now
we've got the mystic fort mystic
fortress if we have to jump back down
into the world we can see through here
good jump animation yeah superhero
London big fun huh
yeah we can see there's like the
necromancer totem it's we're going cast
here so this would all change depending
on sort of the the Warchief who's in
charge uh yeah who you've put in charge
which tribe and then those sort of
behaviors are also going to be out oh
poor caracal and something nice and
satisfying about owning the full person
getting to come back through here and
see all those followers there's like the
population in here increase over time or
is it affected or as your army grows the
way that you grow the scale of the
fortress is basically you have a number
of Garrison's and then each time you add
a new garrison that's a new war chief
that you'll have in the fortress defense
and then it also unlocks another
defensive trait that you can upgrade in
the fortress as well cool
that's quite nice walking around like
good without having to sneak around
everyone's getting down to work can
relive the moment she had I was here
yesterday and I chopped off an aux head
I didn't have a sense do we do we have a
sense of time like I just do we have
time to go after someone else or well uh
so we've been running for like 25
minutes is it uh how long do we how long
do you reckon that will take how long
yeah all thirsty are you for blood I
think we could do yeah let's do let's
try able to see how everyone yeah so
these are good examples of oh look at
peak who we go for we're gonna do
I'm designed as a bodyguard nice that's
easy so that's actually quite fun
because you can now call these guys into
combat whenever so we've got our
bodyguard and we're gonna go after rash
the Impaler all right era Slayer Wow
so he spiked up so it's worth taking a
quick look at his traits fear of Parador
and flammable so this should be so we
have a care ago that we can call in
right yes there he is there he is hey
buddy girl okay
onwards so it's a little bit of a way
nice-lookin open it wait for it so in
terms of the open world is it still
going to be like I can just run anywhere
I want to or is it segmented in any kind
of way so each region like this so for
example then that's an open world but
then on the overworld map the mortal map
you're then traveling between the
different region I mean but we really
wanted to maximize the variety of the
different environments from the real
feel of the lava fields and the classic
mortar on the slopes of Mount Doom in
Gorgoroth through to the kind of huge
caves and cure Athan go to somewhere
more lush here okay
all right there we go okay so this
mission as well these are actually a new
type of mission we have as well as going
after this guy it's an outpost mission
so he's in charge of this outpost this
little base out in the world and by
defeating him that'll actually switch
off the alarms in this outpost so you
can actually make the open world easier
as well okay so drawing him out is gonna
be fairly straightforward just need to
make a lot of noise yep a lot of chaos
and because he's responsible for the
outpost he's going to have to come out
and do something better this guy's just
in there war terror just ran through
that bonfire you know we already tell
there's way more going on in the combat
in the previous game and they don't kind
of wait their turn either they seem to
yeah just dive in and the other thing
with that that's quite good so the AI in
the combat circle like we put a lot into
that but also it varies according to the
difficulty levels because we added
difficulty levels now so now if it is
overwhelming you can put it down to easy
and if you want to just focus on the
story and kind of messing with the
Nemesis system you can do that but our
achievements and trophies attach to
difficulty levels no okay thank you
thanks guys yeah because I have to turn
it down but you don't want to feel like
worse for doing it I hate games all I
have you want to complete the game I
think you know the achievements are much
more I guess a reward for having fun
with the game there are achievements for
doing basically creating things that are
fun stories within the Nemesis system
like you
letting guys through that okay that was
quite on the first game we actually had
a really high proportion of people who
were able to play the game yeah great
it's a fun game to platinum those
systems make it work well it's gonna
take longer to do that this time but
that's just a function of how much
bigger the game is areas Terrace layer
rush another way you're speaking of the
audio guys you actually get the sort of
muffled main voice when they've got
these masks as well okay and in comes
our bodyguard what I like about is that
the attacks look they're more elemental
based so you can sort of have these
burning effects and when you you sort of
like the shadow stun I guess it looks
it's freezing him right see the ice
particles chipping off him which I
think's really cool like actually that's
to have a bit of talking geekery the
spear that he's using is a gloss which
was gil-galad spear beans are in the
basket oh that's incredible that's
pretty cool that's a good that's a good
factor nice yeah the spreading fire is
so nice as well and even if you smash
the barrels that release the grog
that'll spread and then if that catches
fire that'll ignite so we can just have
so much more ki never helps you track
the battlefield better because if you
know like oh yeah someone on fire here
can move away and come back and as you
wish I hope you guys upset now that
we've taken out rash what's gonna happen
to this little outpost okay so now
whenever we return here this is going to
be clear so we've done that mission but
we still got a number of other there's
still more outpost we've got through the
region yeah there's a ton of new
different types of missions we've got
story missions we can pursue got the
towers we've got tons of collectables
and that's actually what we're really
excited this week to show at e3 because
we're going to be opening up the open
world so people can go and play and
explore all that story collectibles
forts nemesis system the whole thing
awesome awesome all right well thank you
so much for come over hello getting me
hot easily thank you so much for coming
and joining us I shadow of war I did
when is it coming out now it's coming
out on October the 10th so thank you for
not too long away just enough time to
replay shadow model absolutely about
halfway through about half a cool cool
Thanksgiving ah for more from this
year's e3 make sure you keep your eyes
peeled to games become or follow us on
YouTube or twitch see it and very soon
for Sony for Sony this is a pre record
so